The Time has come
for me to finally figure out
what's wrong with me! thank you.
This was recommended by one of you guys.
That I do uhhh... MBTI...
Personality test. Now it's already assumed my gender and my location
Disgusting
Okay, if you wanna... I'll leave the link to the test in the description. You can do the test with me.
Let's see what's wrong with ourselves.
Okay. "I like to stay at home."
Agree.
Oh God.
"I like to make definite plans when going out."
Somewhat.
"I avoid public speaking whenever possible." Yes, but not because I don't like public speaking. Just because i don't want
to do it, it takes up too much time to do it well.
"I work best in a group or with others."
While Pub G we Know can't do do us i like to fix things more Than i like to try and fix People
Sure i like tests that Have essay questions i don't even know what that is i prefer to use logic and reason in my Thinking?
Agreed i like to improvise whenever possible
Somewhat sometimes It can Be Good you know this is easy
Morality Should Be Based on justice agree i like to rely on My membrane oh i have no memory like a Goldfish?
You Guys Should Know that i largely accept Things as They are
Disagree how else are People going to improve how Else are People going to learn if
you Just Accept Things from How They are hard you're Just gonna accept
Don't you want a Higher standard
Disgusting i like to procrastinate oh yeah?
I'm
Such a procrastinate i am Largely uncomfortable with my emotions i
Don't know What that means I'M Bored being alone no i'm very Good at entertaining Myself
I like to be focused on the future
yeah i like to talk more Than i
Someone i like to think that i can balance both you know
Not be Just okay i like to follow my head more Than my Heart as someone i like devoting my day
Yeah Shameful shameful okay i prefer Hard Data over Theory
Well Yeah you Need why not how can you argue with hard data
Huh i like to think i'm Thick-Skinned i agree 100% how do you think i got here not by being a Little
My life is Pretty Chaotic Well i
Guess It is but It's not my fault
So i'm gonna go with someone i prefer looking at the overall big picture yeah why not
I want People's love Who doesn't i find it difficult to yell at others Someone
And no it's not That hard i prefer to stand out
no, well i prefer sit but what do you Mean
That Depends is it like
being different or hey look at me i'm standing out you know i'll put someone i
Like to Plan Things at The last minute
no i feel i'm more energetic Than Laid-back nope i
Like to tell People What an event meant to me personally Rather Than Just Subscribing It yeah yeah i think it's more interesting to get
Why People Things are more in okay whatever oh?
Yeah, oh
yeah i
Feel Like I'm gonna Get The worst result from this i tend to believe What others tell me wholeheartedly
no i
Like to know why of things yeah
okay we're almost there we're almost there i like to keep My options open yes i like to go out Rather Than stay Home
Somewhat someone fine i like to perform in front of others Yes i Work best when i'm alone
yes
I'm gonna be an introvert great i like to try fix People more Than uh didn't i answer these i prefer to take a
Multiple-choice test
yeah i think logic is sometimes overrated
Who would Say That logic is overrated i like to prepare for Things Rather Than Just Things on the fly someone
You're Just Asking me the same questions that i put someone on
Morality Should Be Based on Compassion
Somewhat i like to make lists to help My memory, oh?
yeah i
Can't Remember anything i have to make list i have no choice I'm Generally?
Unsatisfied with The Way Things are no
I'm not i like to get my work done as soon as yes it'S 8:30 in the morning i
Need time to be by Myself yes
I'm focused on living in here and Now?
Someone i'd Like to listen more Than no i prefer to follow my heart Over my Head i don't know
This is test ever fucking end Jesus i like to play more Than Work hard oh?
Play Hard more Than Work hard uh
Someone i prefer Theory Over no one i'm easily Hurt by others words
Shut up my life is Pretty organized
I'm gonna sit with someone
no not really i don't know this is too hard Stop Judging me
Thank you i want People's respect more Than Their love
Yeah i can see that i don't Mind Yelling When i need to yes i prefer to fit in then stand out
Yeah okay last page i like to plan far ahead
Someone I Feel like I'M more Laid back Than anything yes
Do You ever meet me in person
When i talk about any event i prefer to keep The facts Rather Than describe What It meant to me
you're asking The same fucking question i Just put stuff Wherever
It Doesn't Need to go in a specific Place
Disagree how else are you gonna find it
God Damn It i love and Get fired Up by parties and social Gathers Somewhat
I'm pretty Skeptical about most Things Someone
okay i like to know the who what and when know things yes here we Go i
Am The duty fulfiller i am serious and quiet
That's true
Interested in Security and Peaceful Living That's true
Extremely Thorough
responsible and dependable
I'll take It well develop Powers of Concentration
That's true When i need to i'm really focused Usually interested in supporting and promoting traditions and
Establishments That Could Not Be Further from the truth i think all of Those Things are stupid
How did that get in there well organized and hardworking They Work steadily Towards identified goals
Yep They can usually accomplish Any task once They have to set Their Mind to it
That's so true That'S so true this is really I'm surprised how accurate That
Description is except This one i don't believe in an establishment at All and
traditions i think is sort of overrated
Maybe I Just Misunderstood some question i am
more introvert Than Extrovert Wish i knew i
Am most sensing Than intuitive i don't know what that means i'm
more Thinking
Than Feeling or is it the opposite
I
Think That's a Good Match though You can't Just have one Without the other and
I'm Judging more Than perceiving
Who am i this is Really interesting i recommend testing trying This out i Am is
Tg Let me know what you guys Got and then in the comments i'm curious okay who else is is tj
Elizabeth The second
George Washington George Bush and of Course Jackie Joyner-Kersee
What is my weakness i'M stubborn
insensitive
Come on i'm not Now Neither of These Things
Some other sting sting and Denzel washington and Natalie Portman
My God
Incredible
Jason Bourne
Thorin Oakenshield The Hobbit is a Launch It's my god this Changes Everything
All Right Let me know what you guys Got and thank you for watching leave a like iF you enjoyed and Squad fam out